pero cientos de estadounidenses te dan
consejos en cómo usarlo eso fue lo que
nosotros experimentamos es lo que nos
sucedió a nosotros no le puede suceder a
cualquiera de ustedes alrededor de todo
el país y por eso queremos hablarles
esta noche exactamente ya sea la policía
dejando salir a todos los criminales el
mismo día mientras para que sigan
haciendo disturbios alentando al caos en
nuestras calles
parece que los demócratas no ven que el
gobierno debe proteger a los ciudadanos
de los criminales si no defienden a los
criminales de los ciudadanos ni una sola
persona en todos los disturbios que he
estado de nuestra cerca nuestra casa
fueron
judicial izados a nosotros y nos
acusaron a nosotros con delitos por
atrevernos a proteger nuestro hogar y
sobre todo esto los activistas que
lideraban esta protesta se pararon
afuera de nuestras casas nos decían no
pueden detener esta revolución semanas
después esa misma persona turista ganó
para ser representante en la casa
representantes y así es cómo ganar
para nosotros es para ganar una elección
general
será una congresista del primer distrito
de missouri
ellos quieren llegar al congreso
ellos quieren apoderarse quieren tener
el poder este es el partido de joe biden
estas son las personas que estarán a
cargo del futuro y del futuro de sus
hijos y están satisfechos
con esparcir el caos quieren eliminar
todos los suburbios terminando con todas
las familias eso traerá crímenes
el presidente de trump inteligentemente
iovine tras todo esto pero joe biden
quiere volver a esto regresar a esto
así que no haga ningún error sin
importar dónde vivan su familia no
estará segura
si están los demócratas de eeuu si en
este momento se defienden por usted y
por los valores de nuestro país las
manifestantes van a tratar de destruirla
usted nos han visto en las pantallas y
no somos las personas que se rinden
gracias a dios yo no son tampoco el
presidente camps va a defender el
derecho de todos los estadounidenses
para proteger su hogar y sus familias
pero más que eso la visión de true para
eeuu es un país en el que tenemos una
oportunidad de trabajar fuertemente
construir la vida que hemos soñado con
los hijos que pueden ser criados en
grandes escuelas en una comunidad donde
nuestra familia puede jugar en los
patios de atrás sin ningún miedo e ir a
la iglesia sin vergüenza y expresar sus
creencias y sin ninguna retribución pero
me trajo la mejor economía que hemos
visto a nuestro país los demócratas nos
han traído nada más que una destrucción
cuando tenemos bases seguras en nuestras
comunidades no vamos a tener la libertad
para construir un futuro para nosotros
para nuestros hijos y para nuestro país
eso es lo que está en juego en este país
en estas elecciones y por eso debemos
reelegir a toronto las gotas dios los
bendiga y dios bendiga a presidente y
dios bendiga a estos estados unidos